we are here you look cute let's go see
the party Kylie Jenner's kids get their
party on at true Thompson's fifth
birthday bash happy birthday I love you
I love you I'm obsessed with it the
beauty Mogul first shared this sweet
moment with her daughter stormy as they
got ready for the celebration get ready
with me we're going to true's birthday
party where are we going
[Music]
thank you for the background noise
show them
our birthday fits
then it was party time for the kiddos we
are here you look cute let's go see the
party
that's Kylie's baby boy air looking
stylish as ever a rare glimpse of the
one-year-old whom she shares with rapper
Travis Scott let's go see the party and
it's no surprise Khloe Kardashian went
all out for her daughter's fifth
birthday I am so obsessed with her and I
love it so much this year's theme the
kids show Octonauts
[Music]
yeah there were tons of balloons
desserts slime making and even custom
backpacks for each child wow
through
three okay good job okay you guys are
matching
and Octonauts
oh and a pinata which took quite a
beating from stormy
[Music]
high five
that's my girl
I got some candy for my baby I love it
notably missing from true's party stormy
and Air's dad Travis back in January A
source told E.T that the on and off
couple are on a break so if they want to
know real personal stuff that like makes
me a little uncomfortable to share then
like I don't think it's that big of a
deal our source added that the mom of
two is trying to stay positive she wants
to keep things cordial with the rapper
for the sake of their family and remain
drama-free the two love and respect each
other and will continue to
co-parents
along with putting the focus on her two
kids Kylie's preparing for the premiere
of the Kardashians season three listen
everyone has their own truth of how they
think something happened I wish I could
tell you this is going to be a mild
relaxing Serene season
it's not and it seems this season the
reality stars ready to make a bigger
impact on the world we have huge
influence what are we doing with our
power
so
let's talk about it just just growing up
in front of the spotlight is
extremely difficult and you're growing
and you're making mistakes
and everyone's judging you so that's
definitely hard but there's so many
blessings that come along with it too
thank you
[Music]